I'd like to do in this video is talk
about the notion of a frame of reference
and this is an introductory video in
future videos we'll go into a lot more
depth but a frame of reference is really
the idea it's a point of view from which
you are measuring things and as we'll
see many of the quantities that we might
measure in physics like velocity or
displacement they could be different
depending on our point of view depending
on which frame of reference we are
measuring from and to get this an
intuitive grasp of it I'm going to draw
the exact same scenario from three
different frames of reference that's the
first one this is the second one and
this is the third one so in this first
frame of reference this first scenario
we're going to talk about the frame of
reference of the ground so if you are a
stationary observer on the ground so you
could imagine this is you here and
you're the person doing the measuring of
let's say let's say we want to measure
velocities so from your point of view
it's since you're stationary relative to
the ground what does the ground velocity
look like well you and the ground appear
to be stationary appear to not be moving
now what if you take out your
instruments for measuring velocity or
you see a change in you see what the
displacement is over a certain time for
the plane in the car and you're able to
see okay look this plane has a velocity
to the right of 250 meters per second
250 meters per second and let's say this
car that is moving quite fast by car
standards is moving to the left at 50
meters per second so this should be
one-fifth of that length let me draw it
a little bit so let's say this is moving
to the left at 50 meters per second well
none of this seems crazy you might be
able to go outside next to the highway
and see well 50 meters per second would
be quite fast but anyway you could you
could observe this type of thing
happening it seems completely reasonable
but what if we were to change our frame
of reference
the point of view from which we are
measuring things so let's take the frame
of reference from of the car well in
this frame of reference let's say you're
sitting in this car and I don't
recommend you doing this while driving
let's say someone else is driving or
it's an autonomous vehicle of some kind
and you take out your your physic
instruments with the stopwatch and you
see what the displacement is of the
ground and the plane over say a second
and you are able to first say from your
point of view like well the car is
stationary the car has a velocity of
zero the car is stationary and you from
your point of view you would actually
measure the ground to be moving you
would see the trees move past you to the
right or behind you if you're moving to
the left and so from your point of view
the ground would actually be look like
it's moving in this direction in that
direction at 50 meters per second it
would look like it's moving behind you
or in this cave the way we're looking at
it to the right at 50 meters per second
now what would the plane look like well
the plane not only would it look like
it's moving to the right at 250 meters
per second not only would it be just at
250 meters per second but relative to
you it looked like it's going even
faster because you're going past it
you're you're you are going to the left
from the stationary from the grounds
point of your 50 meters per second so
the plane to you is going to look like
it's going 250 plus plus 50 meters per
second so the vector would look like
this
and so it would look like it's going to
the right at 300 let me write that in
that orange color at 300 meters per
second now what about from the point of
view of the plane
what if we're talking about the planes
frame of reference why you pause this
video and think about what the
velocities would be of the plane the car
and the ground from the planes point of
view all right now let's work through
this together so now we're sitting in
the plane and once again we shouldn't be
flying the plane we're letting someone
else do that we are physics instruments
and we're trying to measure the
velocities of these other things from my
frame of reference well the plane first
of all is going to appear to be
stationary and that might seem
counterintuitive but if you've ever sat
in a plane especially when there's no
turbulence and the plane is already at
altitude it's not taking off or landing
oftentimes if you close your eyes you
don't know if you are moving in fact if
you close all the windows it feels like
you are in a stationary object that
you're you might as well be in a house
so from the planes point of view you
feel like or from your point of you in
the plane it feels like the plane is
stationary now the ground however looks
like it's moving quite quickly
it looks it'll look like it's moving
past you at 250 at 250 meters per second
whoops try and draw a straight line at
200 at 250 s and those mic tools act
funny
so at 250 meters per second to the left
and the car well it's moving to the left
even faster it's going to be moving to
the left fifty meters per second faster
than the ground is so the car is going
to look not like it's just going 50
meters per second it's going to look
like it's going 50 meters plus another
250 meters per second for a total for
total of 300 meters per second to the
left so this gives you an appreciation
for what frames of references are that
you can view it for this introductory
video is a point of view from which
you're making your measurements now it's
tempting for a lot of folks say well
there must be one correct frame of
reference and a lot of times in our
everyday world you might say well this
may be this is the correct frame of
reference and these are just we're just
imagining this so this is just a mistake
and the reason why we do that is because
we're using the frame of reference of
this big giant thing called the earth
but it actually turns out that none of
these frames of reference are more valid
than the other ones that they are all
equivalent they are all valid frames of
reference not
I shouldn't say they're equivalent we're
obviously measuring getting different
measurements from them but they're all
physically they're all from a physics
point of view equally valid frames of
reference